so in that interesting I we did not set
that up God sets the calls up in the
order they come in God in Kelly and
Kelly sits at the right hand of God not
it so uh anyway she's insulted I can't
actually got her she never gets insulted
Oh
but anyways oh so but I get a call
teenager says I want to put money in
mutual funds to go through college what
did I tell him go to a school that's
affordable work a job and get
scholarships and then I get a call from
this young man who says what I did I
went to school that's affordable a lot
of you never even heard of the college
he went to does he care no does the
people that hired him that are paying
him fifty five thousand dollars a year
at 22 years old care pretty stinkin
impressive right there okay do they care
no did he did get a degree in German
polka history and then wine because
society is unfair because he got a
degree in something that is not
marketable at all no he got a degree in
information systems the hottest degree
levels out there so he was able to land
a job obviously he's a poised young man
you know what else he has on his resume
lots of hard work you know what I want
to see what I'm hiring somebody here in
our company straight out of college work
I'm I'm concerned that they know how to
work not everybody knows how to work
because some of these people out here
were raised by wolves not parents they
were just allowed to run wild and they
have no boundary they have no
self-discipline they have no ability to
leave the cave kill something and drag
at home so work ethic is one of the
greatest gifts you can give your
children you see what his mom and dad
gave him they didn't give him a free
ride to college they gave him work ethic
it's the greatest gift do you think that
young stud right there is going to be
killing it in 20 years when he's 42 is
he gonna be a millionaire you tell me I
think he's going to be a millionaire
that's why I think Tim's going I mean
look at the track record of the guy he's
only 22 he's got his head on them that's
a guy we would hire here you know that's
the kind of guy that's the kind of
person that we look for exactly whether
they're 22 or 42 or 32 or 52 I don't
care but but he's always going to have a
job but I didn't hear any kind of a
victim thing I didn't hear anybody
saying they owed him anything there was
no entitlement you know what he did he
wouldn't solve these problems and he
went he went and did it it's so
refreshing and that's the kind of that
that's the answer to your college loan
problem you know why colleges charge
what they charge they're both lines
about what colleges charge you know why
they do because people pay them that you
quit paying them they'll quit doing it
you know why they pay them that because
they borrow the money from the
government and you and I are so stupid
we insured the loans we're called
taxpayers and so there's enough they're
not even using real money they're using
monopoly money to pay for their
education so they don't look at the
price and so the college goes oh look at
the price we're going to look at the
price we're going to charge you but
fifty two thousand dollars a year when
the college down the streets five
thousand dollars a year mm-hmm something
to think about it a student loan problem
student loan being federally insured by
the government with no limitations on it
to amount anything is what's caused the
price of college to go through the roof
it's called supply demand if you had a
ninth grade class in economics you'd
understand the basic concept but we have
hope because we have Timmy's out there
there's real ones there's another
generation of bright people coming on
amongst the other ones but there's the
good ones in there too people I'm seeing
them all the time this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]